bonjour pierre galand
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france un sondage intéressant qui révèle
donc les jeunes seraient favorables
finalement d'avoir un pouvoir un peu
plus autoritaire pourquoi avoir réalisé
ce sondage
écoutez c'est parce que en belgique que
tout ce qui est politique est très
compliqué nous sommes deux communautés
trois communautés linguistiques nous
sommes de réussir trois régions deux
communautés en fait tout s'est tu pour
les jeunes est assez compliqué complexe
à comprendre et donc ce sondage à à
l'effet de la diagnostique intéressant
parce que bon il faut savoir que les 47%
serre ceux qui sont radicalement pour un
pouvoir pouvoir fort et ceux qui sont
plutôt pour un pouvoir plus clair plus
plus en plus accessible et donc je crois
que il ya là un effort de faire un
diagnostic et il nous appartient il
appartient aux politiques de chercher
des solutions il ya un autre
enseignement de ce sondage plus d'un
citoyen sur quatre trouvent que la
situation politique en belgique se
rapproche d'une dictature alors est-ce
qu'on peut y voir l'effet de la crise
sanitaire
mais j'y reviens linverse parce que
quand vous regardez le sondage les
citoyens belges dans leur ensemble plus
de 70 % sont satisfaits de la manière
dont on a géré la crise sanitaire en
belgique donc ce n'est pas tant la le
problème la question aujourd'hui c'est
les citoyens sont demandeurs de beaucoup
plus de participation les citoyens sont
demandeurs de beaucoup plus de clarté
dans les débats sont demandeurs aussi de
savoir dans quel sens on est en train
d'orienter notre pays et tout ça est
compliqué complexé par le fait que la
belgique est un petit pays membres de
l'europe que l'europe elle-même vie ces
convulsions que tout ça a des effets et
les jeunes essaie d'exprimer un mal-être
malaise par rapport à tout cela si je
comprends bien c'est plutôt une nouvelle
crise identité c'est vrai qu'entre la
wallonie et la flandre il ya quand même
beaucoup de différence
vous savez c'est très vrai et l'économie
est plus florissante en flandre elle est
plus organisée elle est plus proche de
l'accès aux énergies la wallonie a
souffert énormément cet été souvenez il
y a eu cette catastrophe vraiment un
séisme avec les inondations et donc il a
fallu pour le gouvernement wallon
trouver les moyens de venir en aide aux
populations
et cela se ressent il y a des
insatisfactions qui sont exprimés mais
plus le pouvoir un proche des citoyens
plus on s'aperçoit que les gens ont par
exemple fêter leur bourgmestre dans
certaines villes pour tout ce qu'il a
avait engagé lors des catastrophes il a
aussi était observable que beaucoup de
flamands sont allés aider les
populations wallonne en détresse encore
aujourd'hui vous avez des jeunes
flamands qui sont en train d'aider des
populations
donc il ne faut pas non plus hyper
dramatiser la situation
je crois qu'au contraire c'est un espèce
de cri d'alarmé qui est lancé par les
jeunes de dire écoutez nous on y croit
on n'y comprend plus rien essayé de nous
faire comprendre comment on peut assurer
le vivre ensemble est ce qu'on peut
faire un parallèle selon vous avec ce
qui se passe en france et ces jeunes qui
se rangent derrière le polémiste eric
zemmour un personnage plutôt autoritaire
nous n'avons pas aujourd'hui cette
situation en belgique et heureusement
pour nous d'ailleurs ne vont pas le fait
un oiseau ni en tout cas il n'y a pas de
mouvements d'extrême droite en flandre
il y à une extrême droite assez
puissante mais actuellement il ya un
cordon sanitaire qui jouent encore fait
que les principes démocratiques
fonctionne simplement je crois qu'il
faut essayer de comprendre aussi un
phénomène c'est que notre pays était un
pays dans lequel il y avait le politique
et le politique a toujours été très
critiquée et il y avait entre le citoyen
et le politique une série de corps
intermédiaires les corps intermédiaires
c'est notre les syndicats syndicats sont
très puissants en belgique les les
organisations non gouvernementales les
associations tant de citoyens sur le
plan intérieur que sur le plan
international sont extrêmement actifs
extrêmement organisés extrêmement aussi
en liaison avec le pouvoir politique
c'est à dire le législatif
essentiellement salé le parlement et
cela donnait à la belgique une espèce de
cohérence aujourd'hui il y a une
certaine un certain affaiblissement de
ces corps intermédiaires et donc il ya
lieu de retrouver comment on organise la
participation citoyenne et est
finalement le roi belge dans tout ça
c'est lui finalement qui incarne à
l'unité du pays qu'est ce que demandent
les belges
vous savez les belges eux vis-à-vis de
la royauté son son estime que c'est
probablement le moins mauvais système de
liaison entre eux et donc c'est le roi
qui est chargé chaque fois qu'il ya une
crise gouvernementale
d'organiser les consultations tout le
monde accepte d'aller présenter ses
propositions au palais royal et c'est le
roi qui va simplement servir de trait
d'union entre les communautés c'est
important et en ce sens je crois que en
belgique pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
réclamations ou de pression pour aller
vers un système républicain plutôt que
royal nous sommes une démocratie avec un
système qui est organisée autour du
palais royal
merci beaucoup pierre galand pour toutes
ces explications en direct sur arte
france